[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
pour le sommaire en football ont joué ce
week-end le 8e tour de la coupe de
france sous versailles qui évolue en n3
s'est incliné 4 à 2 à domicile face à
lens en démérité dans une ambiance
électrique le résumé du match dans ce
magazine course à pied nous recevrons
dans ce set 8 sport 6,10 à diallo cette
ligne montrent un des jacquots plus de
180 marathon et ultra marathon depuis
la dame ans il a effectué 13 marathon
pieds nus en 12 semaines
rugby dans le championnat de division
honneur chevreuil s'est imposée
difficilement 32 à 24 dans le derby face
au sky rugby reportage à suivre
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv et 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football et le
8e tour de la coupe de france versailles
qui évolue en nationale 3 failli
réaliser le plus bel exploit de son
histoire ce samedi joueurs de la cité
royale se sont inclinés à 4 à 2 face au
racing club de lens un club de ligue 2
des images de à grégory canal est un
montage de pierre guillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ambiance des grands jours à versailles
3000 supporters habillés de blanc et
bleu aux couleurs des sang et or se sont
donné rendez vous au stade mont boron
objectif encourager leurs protégés lors
de ce 8e tour de coupe de france entre
versailles et lancent tous voulu venir
soutenir fc versailles
ces contrôles ans aujourd'hui c'est
historique et du coup et jusqu'aux
toilettes la journée et l'ambiance est
montée d'un cran à l'entrée des joueurs
les versaillais qui évolue en n3 font
jeu égal avec lens club de ligue 2 les
deux équipes rejoignent les vestiaires
dos à dos après un deuxième but
versailles est marqué par chalali juste
avant la mi temps
alors sans la magie là qu'une approche
tout le monde est mobilisé le public et
surtout les joueurs qui font une super
première mi temps et on espère qu'on
passera devant en deuxième mi temps
juste avant la mi-temps on espère que ça
va tomber alors taper sur la tête nous
attribue pour qu'elle le troisième but
en deuxième période malgré le bruit des
tambours et des chants dans les tribunes
les lensois accéléré marque deux buts
pour l'emporter 4 à 2 fin de l'aventuré
pour ces courageux vers s'est dit malgré
tout et la défaite pleine et c est parce
que on abordait ce match là pour par le
remporter on n'a pas remporté ce match
mais je tiens à saluer le courage
l'abnégation et le coeur que mes joueurs
ont omis sur ce match au fil du match
cette seconde mi temps on a on a pris un
but assez vite mais on a on a baissé
physiquement et c'est là où c'était plus
dur pour nous après l'élimination de
versailles les yvelinois ne compte plus
aucun représentant en coupe de france
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour vivre
de nouvelles émotions football toujours
ont joué également dans le championnat
de d1 de district les clubs saint
quentinois ont brillé ce week-end mort
par renouer avec la victoire et s'impose
3 1 à domicile contre le chesnay plaisir
domine à domicile montesson sur le score
de 3 à 2 et en cours est allé chercher
le match nul sur le terrain de
marly-le-roi 2 partout dans les autres
rencontres sartrouville et hardricourt
se neutralisent 1 partout même score
entre le fc mantois et gargenville le
championnat est dominé par guyancourt
avec 18 points plaisir et marly droit
complète le podium et reste en embuscade
à un petit point
on laisse de côté les ballons de
football pour parler basket en nationale
3 féminine le chesnay-versailles n'en
finit plus de gagner
neuvième victoire de la saison pour les
yvelinois ce week-end contre
gravenchonnais le fcv s'est imposée 62 à
52 à domicile et conserve la tête de la
poule e avec deux points d'avancé sur le
havre
prochain match dimanche prochain à 15h30
toujours à domicile contre la baule en
bois saunière martynov
on ouvre maintenant une page course à
pied nous avons une nouvelle fois la
chance de recevoir dans cette émission
le marathonien à 6,10 à diallo bonsoir
bonsoir
alors je vais vous présenter vous
présenter pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne vous connaissent pas encore vous êtes
ini montain vous avez 63 ans vous avez
couru depuis 2010 187 marathon et ultra
à marathon dans 71 pays et sept
continents alors expliquez nous pourquoi
vous êtes lancés dans cette aventure
tout d'abord j'ai eu la chance à gta
chicago en 2010 et à chicago
le marathon de chicago c'est plus de 40
mille coureurs qui sont passés en 2008
devant chez moi et ensuite derrière chez
moi en 2009 ils ont fait la même chose
et quand vous voyez ces gens quarante
mille personnes ce sont des gens comme
vous et moi
comme tout le monde si eux ils peuvent
courir quand les kilomètres et pourquoi
pas moi langues
mais il a fallu trois ans la troisième
année j'ai décidé de faire comme eux
donc plutôt que de le voir passer de
l'école avec eux alors vous avez
toujours la même passion
mais huit ans après oui oui en fait
c'est un coureur de marathon couvrir de
longues distances et la destinée de tous
les humains donc sèche de le pet
avant on courait pour attraper les
animaux pour manger où trouver de l'eau
pour trouver les fruits pendant des
millions d'années les ancêtres ont
développé ses capacités de couvrir de
longues distances que nous avons tous
ces rites et donc nous sommes tous
capables de faire et quelque part en le
cms et enfouis dans le subconscient
donc en fait il suffit qu'on se réveille
qu'on le fasse une fois qu'on dirait à
chelles
c'est bien ça c'est bien ce que je fais
c'est intéressant parce que comme vous
pourrez le malade en fait on a les
récompenses un terme dans dolphin ya pas
seulement la santé le bien-être monsieur
on est heureux parce qu'en fait c'est ce
que c'est oui oui c'est ce que les
humains et les supposés faire pour la
survie de l'espèce pour amener à manger
aux bébés pour que l'espèce puisque le
vivre c'est naturel c'est naturel alors
vous avez décidé de vous lancer dans la
course à pied pieds nus également vous
avez réalisé là dernièrement 13 marathon
pieds nus en 12 semaines
oui je crois que ce n'est pas encore
terminé maintenant il ya une plus c'est
un de plus menacé 13,1
14 14 centres et semaine puisque arrêté
parce que dimanche là j'ai couru le 14e
marathon pieds nus hebdomadaire à malaga
donc il ya jusqu'à malaga à pieds nus
pourquoi en fait déjà collé de mal at on
sait faire comme les ancêtres qui
poursuivent et les bêtes pour les
attraper c'était long nous on a la
chance d'ailleurs comparé on sait que
ses 42 km eux c'est l'animal et c'est
costa 6 déterminer le parcours et la
distance puisqu'il fallait ramener à
manger à la cantine
mais une fois qu'on le fait en fait les
gens sont blessés les gens sont abîmés
les ya des abandons les jeunes terminent
les canaris km ensuite ils peuvent plus
marcher
oh il souffre
et tout ça je suis arrivé à la
conclusion c'est à cause des jeux sur
six ont couru les 42 km il faut comme
les ancêtres parce que il était capable
de tutoyer inclusion tous les jours elle
était capable de courir autant autant de
fois que nécessaire pour manger s'il
courait avec nos chaussures le basket
actuelle isoler terminé comme nous c'est
à dire
incapables de chasser pendant deux
semaines pendant deux mois l'espèce
c'est la mort de faim serait pas là
quand les chaussures est-ce que c'est
plus éprouvant peut-être qu'un marathon
normal est-ce que vous par exemple vous
éprouvez plus de mal à récupérer après
et notamment au niveau de vos pieds j'ai
rien du tout vous avez raison j'ai couru
tout mais n'en a d'ailleurs vos pieds
sont intactes mais piano rien je voulais
les montrer ou kg rien ni les pieds ni
les jambes
c'est vraiment une promenade c'est 42 km
dans les rues de malaga 1 qui conquit et
qui sont en fait une promenade très
agréable je commence comme ça et je
cours comme ça je parle avec les gens on
discute on est en jeu
j'essaie d'expliquer aux gens qui sont
surpris hier beaucoup de gens disaient
un magret me d'y venir
vous voyez je voyais la douleur qu'il
ressentait sur le visage alors que moi
j'ai rien ils doivent demander à ceux
qui portent des chaussures si ça va et
vous pouvez le faire partout
vous pouvez courir partout sans
chaussures ou est-ce qu'il faut
certaines conditions climatiques en
termes tels alors vêtements aussi sur le
homo sapiens en somme les individus de
l'espèce homo sapiens un autre climat
normal c'est lé climat chaud et humide
s'est dit c'est le climat tropical qu'on
appelait le paradis quand quelqu'un va
aux antilles à aller au paradis c'est
notre climat normal c'est à dire que
dans ce climat là tous les indices
chaque individu d'homo sapiens peut
survivre nu toute l'année les régions
froides n'est pas c'est pas du tout le
froid n'est pas notre climat normal
parce qu'on n'a pas de poils n'a pas de
plumes nous pouvons à survivre l'hiver
ici à saint quentin en yvelines
grâce aux vêtements que nous portons à
nos logements qui sont chauffés ou
va-t-il chauffée à dire on est obligé on
est on est obligé transformer
l'environnement pour les rendre
habitables tournons notre espèce
donc il n'est pas question de grépiac
salésienne ya 50 ans ni bassila là je
marche pieds nus dans la ville il ya des
gens qui m'ont vu je marche pieds nus
je marche beaucoup d'air filmera de
j'habite à trois kilomètres que d'ici je
suis peiné à pied peut-être subir vos
invités qui viennent à pied de quoi km
et j'ai rencontré personne n'y a que des
voitures qui passent devant derrière
non non non ce mât quand il fait froid
c'est à dire quand on a besoin de mettre
des gants
parce qu on a froid en main on doit
aussi protéger les pieds c'est la seule
circonstance qui implique qu'on protège
les pièces contre le froid en fait parce
que c'est pas notre climat et vous
arrivez quand même des mésaventures dans
pacé en courant pieds nus bas au début
on est au début parce qu'on a tous des
pieds de bébé
si on a porté des chaussures toute sa
vie où pendant quatre ou cinq décennies
comme c'était mon cas on a les pieds de
bébé vous savez si vous avez les gens
qui ont un plâtre ou un plâtre pendant
12 semaines
il voit très bien que le muscle
s'atrophie complètement les choses
fonctionnent comme des plâtres des pieds
ça empêche les pieds de se développer
les pièces des organes très complexe
avec beaucoup d'articulation des tendons
des muscles à les chaussures font que
les transforme en organe passif et dont
canton
quand on ne dit pas quand on enlève les
chaussures non si on met pas les
chaussures c'est pas le jeu si on met
pas les chaussures et consorts de ses
choix on se rend tout de suite compte
que il ya du pain sur la planche avant
de s'habituer je commençais tu commencé
ici en marchant dans la rue de montigny
il ya trois ans donc on peut s'adapter
assez vite mais au début oui c'est une
épreuve et vous avez créé un mouvement
on peut le dire d'ailleurs sur votre
t-shirt on voit voilà ce qu elles sont
courir pieds nus rejoint la tendance est
ce que vous avez le sentiment que les
gens vous suivent
bon allez jamais coûte il se pose des
questions quand quand les gens mais voit
que les pieds nus dans un marathon
ils sont blessés isolement partout ils
voient que moi je n'ai rien du tout ils
vont aimer psg rien du tout il se pose
des questions
et quand je vous ai dit maintenant à
c'est mon 14e en treize semaines
abou ânes ou la voilà c'est juste à fait
l'idée de faire ces casemates ont un 14e
semaine partout dans le monde c'est pour
que les gens puissent fois qu'il voit
pas ce que c'est difficile à croire
on est tellement convaincu des vertus
protectrices de basket que c'est pour ça
que je le fais et je le fais toujours à
clôturer pendant la course parce que je
me suis dit pourquoi je vais pas
inventer des douleurs il y en a pas pour
que les gens se rendent compte et ça
marche vous pensez que tout le monde un
jour on lèvera ces chaussures pour les
battra pas les clubs à ne pas laisser
passer de tels pas les maîtres à penser
que c'est possible
bah ce serait pas mal et ceux qui le
font
quand on fait mal at home pnud là
le bien-être au corps et sans la joie le
bonheur ça n'a pas de prix
avec 2 milliards d'euros vous pouvez pas
acheter ça mais il faut le faire mais
bon on peut se rendre compte et
d'ailleurs alors pourquoi j ans âge là
le un de vos invités me disait ah chez
moi c'est toujours pieds nus à logis dit
comment vous sentez sow son visage
le simple fait de penser la situation
des pieds ni chez lui son visage grêlé
de bonheur il me dit à un autre et bien
j -p
je n'ai pas besoin de me le dire je suis
sur votre visage donc 2 que les gens se
mettent pied nique sur la plage que ce
soit sur le sable ou chez eux ou la
pelouse parce qu'on a peur on a peur du
but y va on veut sur l'herbe de que les
gens le font et qu'ils évoquent du voix
devant le collège sur le visage
l'umq sait et on a la chance de voir
le but ultime parce qu'en fait moi de là
jusqu'au coup les matelots sur le bitume
comme qu'elle va se passer dans les
forêts comme le marathon de droit en
seine-maritime et j'ai couru le siège de
septembre il ya 7 km dans une forêt
alors il met sur le site internet
ailleurs à sept kilomètres de pleine
nature
mais moi ça pose des problèmes parce que
je suis pas encore prêt pour courir dans
la forêt mais je suis quand même allé
j'ai marché j'ai couru et les gens
pensaient que j'avais ma on est là vous
plier aux agents mais assure qu'ils
avaient mal donc je marchais je termine
à moins de 4
dernière question votre chien marathon
c'est qu'en petit bassin dimanche
prochain pianiste sera le 15e
que je cours je vais courir pieds nus
c'est cher à pise en italie merci à vous
d'être venu sur ce plateau si diallo on
continuera à vous suivre avec attention
assuré avec attention vos prochaines
performances pieds nus on l'a bien
compris merci à vous en tout cas je ne
joue pas pieds nus mais avec des
crampons aux pieds dans le championnat
honneur les rugbymans de chevreuse se
sont imposés ce week-end contre leurs
voisins du sky rugby dans un match sous
tension le score 32 à 24 le résumé du
match
avantage signé à jules grevy un derby à
rebondissements entre chevreuse et le
sky rugby dans le championnat honneur
plus fort physiquement les chevrotins
dominent les débats en début de match et
inscrivent deux essais avant la mi-temps
le sky réagi arrive au courage a marqué
un décès pour revenir à 10 à 7
faut être plus discipliné surtout parce
qu'on a pris beaucoup trop de pénalités
pour pouvoir exister
et si on règle ça et qu'on avait
vraiment un peu de possession on peut
passer devant sur la fin du match et ses
miracles pour eux qu'ils soient à 10
avec eux sur l'a7 10 pour eux
l'important n'était contrôle vent c'est
bien pour eux pour cent ces cadeaux je
faisais et puis on va pouvoir écarter
des ballons après chez eux dès le retour
des vestiaires les consignes sont
respectées chevaux ce pouce et arrive
accentué son avance mais le sky rugby à
n'abdique pas y arrive à égaliser grâce
à un essai et une pénalité à 17 partout
à déclic pour les chevrotins qui
marquent deux essais en fin de match
pour assurer leur victoire
score final 32 à 24 quand même la fierté
parce que on savait que ça va être
compliqué c'est une équipe qui joue le
haut de tableau et malgré tout les a
tenus on les a tenues avec nos armes
avec le jeu et la solidarité après
dommage ça nous ça nous sourit pas mais
on va continuer à travailler en vertu on
était optimiste on a gagné mais
son manque les deux sans manquer de
respect aux sky je pense que c'est
normal qu'on gagne largement est par
contre
voilà qui est pas le bonus ça c'est pas
normal par contre pour nous au
classement chevreuse 2000 le championnat
honneur avec six victoires en huit
matches de son côté le sky rugby reste
7e avec 15 points
les deux équipes joueront leur dernière
rencontre de l'année ce dimanche au 16
décembre
victoire impérative pour passer de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année toujours
dans le championnat honneur dans la
poule une versailles et toujours
invaincus les joueurs de la cité royale
se sont une nouvelle fois imposé contre
montmorency une victoire à l'extérieur
12 à 8 au classement les versets ils
sont toujours premier avec quatre points
d'avancé surmonter son prochain match
dimanche prochain à domicile vers celle
recevra le skiff 7e du championnat
toujours en rugby mais cette fois ci
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir l'équipe en forme du moment a
subi un coup d'arrêt sur le terrain du
havre les plaisirs roy se sont inclinés
à 17 à 12 face aux normands et
obtiennent tout de même le point de
bonus défensif
au classement les ivy noir restent
neuvièmes du championnat et que trois
points d'avancé sur le premier relégable
on va sortir aller voile maintenant dans
cette émission le skipper versailles et
de comme un seul homme
éric bellion est enfin arrivé en
guadeloupe il a terminé sa route du rhum
ce samedi 8 décembre sont en 34 jours et
10 heures le sportif est arrivé 10e
concurrents de sa catégorie mais la
ligne d'arrivée de la compétition
étaient officiellement fermés depuis le
7 décembre ne sera pas à classer sur
cette course unis situations
anecdotiques car le versailles et avait
fait le choix de ne pas aller vite sur
cette course pour lancer un message sur
la décélération il enregistrait cette
vidéo juste avant son arrivée
on arrive demain bon c'était un pari un
peu fou mais
voilà c'était notre défi et puis je me
dis que tout ça c'est finalement très
peu d'importance
qui compte c'est en boucle tous les deux
cette aventure qu'on ait réussi à à
passer des messages à faire en sorte que
plein de gens se sentent concernés aient
envie de réfléchir avec nous et qu'on va
finir la course va faire le tour de la
guadeloupe on va faire tout le trajet
jusqu'au bout tout le parcours
pour respecter ce mythe extraordinaire
qu'est la route du rhum encore un grand
bravo à éric bellion pour saha route du
rhum on passe à notre page agenda
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda part du handball
un match d'entraînement entre l'équipe
féminine du paris 92 et les jeunes du
sky vgp est organisée ce lundi 17
décembre palais des sports de plaisir
pour nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
recevons sur ce plateau l'un des
organisateurs patrick chehab ainsi que
deux joueurs du sky vgp lucas saugy et
alexandre scellier bonsoir
bonjour comment avez vous fait pour
organiser un tel événement patrick du
fait comme des relations un petit peu
assez proche avec le paris 92 on s'était
dit pourquoi pas à monter une opération
inédite de ce genre les garçons contre
des filles c'est autrement c'est
pourquoi pas ça a été assez simple à
monter
oui c'est pas très compliqué le problème
c'est de trouver la date qui va qui va
bien quoi donc
initialement n'était pas prévu à ce
lundi là mais bon pour des raisons de
programmation notamment à cause de
l'euro 2010 8 en cours il a fallu
décaler vers la balle fait bien oui
verbal féminin et les dirigeants ont été
emballés du paris 92 tout de suite des
couleurs avait annoncé la mise en place
sont en berne en os à l'entraîneur
arnaud gandais donc qui le dit ben ok on
fait on peut faire ce genre d'opération
enfin se met en relation avec avec les
élus le directeur des sports de la ville
le plaisir et puis leur entraîneur donc
savoir si ça les intéresse ou appui du
côté des joueurs du coup comment vous
avez réagi à cette annonce
vous savez depuis quand déjà alors on
l'a pris un mois et c'est vrai que au
début on était impressionné on s'est dit
mais on va jouer contre des joueuses
comme ça ça nous faisait un peu peur on
s'est dit on les a vus jouer qu'à la
télé c'est impressionnant comme de la
peur même
oui un peu un petit peu elles sont
impressionnantes à la télé on lit
vu en vrai pour la plupart du coup mais
après on a toujours envie de se
confronter à des joueurs de ce niveau là
quand même
enfin cédé des pros et puis c'est un peu
notre est enfin je pense que c'est le
rêve de beaucoup de jeunes de toujours
vouloir basse confrontera des progrès
quand vous avez réagi quand vous allez
après ça vous alexandre et bas je
pensais justement qu enfin que même si
c'est un match amical
enfin pour avoir la victoire ça va être
très très dur mais bon c'est vrai que je
pense qu'on va principalement prendre du
plaisir même si comme tout le match on
veut gagner quand même justement ça
c'est un match d'entraînement sur le
papier un patrick fiable mais est ce
qu'il n'ya pas quand même cet esprit de
compétition comme séville oui on aime
bien faire face à une équipe comme ça
donc c'est sûr ce sont des
professionnels ils vont pas tout mais
c'est quand même du haut doubs où on est
et on
ils ont fait leur parcours de coupe
d'europe donc c'est vrai que c'est quand
même ça ça montre aussi à d'autres
personnes que ça ça sert à la promotion
à la fois du handball je dirais qu'en
général masculin et féminin
ça peut permettre du côté du paris 4e
nous à certaines joueuses aussi
peut-être de gagner leur place aussi
dans l'équipe première à votre avis non
plus le cas c'est bon là c'est un match
d'entraînement donc
surtout il faut éviter absolument les
blessures pour port tout le monde c'est
clair donc le but c'est de se faire
plaisir surtout et se donner du plaisir
à ceux qui vont être là est ce qu'il ya
des choses que vous admirez vous de
votre côté
c'est vrai qu'on les a vus jouer jeu
s'était produite notamment vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
vous y étiez ou pas du tout on n'y était
pas mais on nous avait subi beaucoup
entendu parler je crois que ces jours là
qu'on avait eue en mal justement on
n'avait pas pu y aller mon avait
regretté quand vous êtes tout le temps
compétition c'est pour ça tous les
week-ends c'est une compétition
patricia justement ce vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ces événements
qui se sont passés là bas avec le paris
92 avant anciennement ici paris est-ce
que ça a contribué un lien avec les
yvelines a créé un lien en fait que
il se trouve qu'il y à différentes
opérations sur la région île de france
par exemple dans le 95 il ya le fameux
challenge tibi tournoi international
juniors masculins et donc jusqu'ici les
yvelines il n'y a pas trop de de toi ce
genre donc c'était l'occasion de de
profiter et puis de faire une opération
originale aussi parce que faire du
handball dans un vélodrome ça c'est ce
n'est jamais fait et puis le fait de
voir la première fois à plus de 5000
personnes
cette année là au mois de février 4 700
personnes sachant qu'il y a au maximum
1000 personnes qui ont pu me licencier
conte qui sont venus mais ça veut dire
que les autres ce sont des non licenciés
j'ai donc le handball prend c'est un
match qui peut vous permettre de grandir
en tant qu'équipe bas votre avis oui
forcément enfin là c'est pas le même
niveau c'est des vrais joueurs et des
joueuses qui font du hand depuis depuis
des années
et puis forcément ils ont beaucoup plus
d'expérience et lorsqu'on joue contre
des plus forts forcément on a envie de
se mettre à niveau et oui je pense que
on peut c'est un match qui peut nous
permettre de nous améliorer
vous comptez peut être discuté à la fin
du match avec des joueuses la victoire
après les selles fils et sa peau mais
elles ont une formation que nous on n'a
pas eu elles sont passés par des centres
d'entraînement et des centres de
formation on n'a jamais eu ça me du coup
ses rangs ce serait important qu'on
parle avec elle parce que elles sont
habituées à cette compétition que nous
on n'a pas forcément tout le temps mais
ils ont sûrement beaucoup plus de
compétition vous entraînez vous
connaissez à peu près la date du match
puis depuis hier - est-ce que vous
entraînez plus vieux romans depuis un
mois est ce que votre coach
un mouvement désormais un peu plus à
l'entraînement banon enfin justement on
le sait que de cul depuis un mois et
puis on devait on devait terminer on
devait terminer notre championnat donc
surtout avec un gros match contre le psg
on a vraiment plus travailler sur le psg
que que le match que le futur match mais
mais non non on n'a pas
justement notre note niveau
d'entraînement est resté stable ces cinq
jours jusqu'au dernier jour alors le
match est il ouvert au public est ce
qu'on a eu également la voir ce match
d'où le monde est invité
vous devez dire que les deux cent mille
et quelques habitants de saint quentin
sont cordialement invités à suivre ce
match portes ouvertes
mais combien de passes des ce que 1200
1200 faudra y venir tôt en fait ouais
est-ce que c'est gratuit c'est gratuit
et c'est une motivation supplémentaire
justement de jouer devant un public 1200
personnes potentiellement forcément
forcément de 1200 personnes s'est enfin
vous avez pas forcément l'habitude mais
voilà c'est ça c'est c'est pas l'une de
nos premières fois mais mais c'est vrai
que 1200 personnes c'est important enfin
on aura beaucoup plus la pression on a
dit ça nous est arrivé une fois pendant
un tournoi de jouer devant autant de
personnes et on s'est aperçu vraiment
que l'ambiance changé et notre
motivation aussi
quant à 1200 personnes qui crient après
qu'on ait mis un but c'est
impressionnant et on a envie de se
donner encore plus pour leur faire
du coup je pense que ça va nous motiver
dernière question autour de celle état
d'un pronostic sur cette rencontre
je dirais plein essor mais qui va gagner
je dirais peu importe pour moi c'est
l'essentiel c'est qu'on fasse du beau
jeu et surtout semblé suivre sans lui
semblait sûr que je veux quand même
gagné
karine gagné mais juste pour vous
j'espère qu'on va gagner mais ça va être
compliqué le message est passé en tout
cas merci à tous les trois les revenus
sur ce plateau sera présent bien sûr
lundi prochain pour couvrir à cette
rencontre on a hâte d'y être en tout cas
merci beaucoup
on continue cet agenda par la
présentation officielle du parcours du
trophée des entreprises qui était
organisée jeudi dernier à la commanderie
des templiers à elancourt pour cette
douzième édition 220 équipe de 3
personnes venues du territoire sont
attendus le jeudi 13 juin prochain les
sportifs s'affronteront sur des épreuves
de course à pied de vtt de canoë ou
encore de golf nouveauté cette année le
parcours devrait faire un peu plus de 9
km un de plus que l'année dernière
l'épreuve reste accessible à tous on
écoute l'une des organisatrices celui
dit
de bastille l'objectif c'est que ce soir
est qui reste avant tout accessible au
plus grand nombre
vous pouvez le faire sans être un
sportif aguerri
après c'est vrai que quelques footings
en amour ça c'est dallas à faire face et
le raid un peu plus facilement mais on
propose justement des entraînements tous
les vendredis du mois de mai avant avant
trophée c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv 70 vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]